>>Hi I'm Paula Braun. I'm an entrepreneur in
residence with the Centers for Disease Control and Prevention.
>>Hi. I'm Tate Gilchrist.
I'm a senior business developer at Cerner Corporation out of Kansas City, Missouri.
>>Tate, could you give us a high level overview of Cerner's history and current business?
>>Sure, Sure. So, Cerner was started several decades ago
by three very visionary gentlemen
sitting at a picnic table in North Kansas City, Missouri.
We've grown from that time in very humble roots into
a global healthcare information technology company in numerous countries the Middle East,
Australia, the UK, all over the United States,
Canada and we use a variety of
technologies to serve the healthcare systems that we support.
Cloud-based technologies such as SMART on FHIR,
population health cloud based technologies.
Cerner's committed a substantial amount of money to R&D every year and we do this in
an effort to really drive the innovation for
that's going to be needed to support the health of patients across the globe.
>>Great. And Cerner was one of the first to support SMART as
a platform for allowing third party developers to contribute to your ecosystem.
>>Yeah.
>>Can you share some insight and why you did that?
>>Yeah, again and I think it comes back to, you know,
the three gentlemen that I spoke of our founders
so very visionary individuals and they recognize that the way that we're currently
doing business and the way that the market is currently set
up is really not sustainable if we're going to achieve
the things that we want to achieve and so they
decided that we needed to pursue being an open platform company.
Taking the vast amounts of data that
our clients are generating and the patients are generating when they're
using our core EMR and through the use of APIs
to be able to open it up so that third party developers can come in with
these brilliant ideas that maybe we hadn't even
thought of or maybe we just hadn't gotten around to thinking
of yet and be going to take them and give them the tools to come in and take
their application and put it inside of our EMR so that
our providers and for the patients themselves can use too.
It's a very, very exciting time in our company's history and I'm very,
very happy to be a part of it.
>>Great. Now some have commented that SMART on FHIR is an academic exercise.
What's your take on that from your perspective at Cerner?
>>No longer an academic exercise, you know.
Cerner has been working with Argonaut group.
And others for several years now and SMART on FHIR.
And ah, it's, it's real now,
so we have some actual app usage.
We have numerous clients that have deployed the API,
that have built their own applications.
We have clients that have taken applications
from third party vendors that have used our tools,
that we have openly available to anyone,
even our competitors to be able to use
and have taken those applications and put them into
their production environments and were even started
seeing some early outcomes out of the use of those apps.
So while it's true,
it is very, very earl, we're very,
very excited about the progress that's been made and
the exponential growth curve is really starting to ramp up.
So we're very excited to see what the future will hold.
>>Surveys of physicians show that using electronic medical records can be inefficient.
What role do you think that apps can play in this?
>>Well, I think one of the great hopes with SMART on
FHIR app is that this is really an opportunity for us to
fully engage the physician in
the workflow process and in some cases in the app development process.
We've got numerous examples now of companies and of individuals that
have almost taken the classical example
of medicine so the bench to bedside approach, right?
A drug or device would have to go through a clinical vetting process, a study, etc.
Healthcare Information Technology is typically not that way but with SMART on FHIR,
we can have innovative developers and innovative individuals that can take
clinically vetted content that is specific to
the physician and can now take that and put that in the physician's workflow.
The hope is that, by using that,
that would advance patient care,
increase physician satisfaction and a rising tide is going to lift all boats.
>>Cerner has also announced that it will be supporting CDS Hooks.
How do you think that that will help with
the further adoption of clinical decision support tools?
>>Well, CDS Hooks is very,
very exciting and we have a numerous number of developers that are
anxiously awaiting our ability to be able to deploy it for their use.
From a broad concept, you know,
a provider doesn't want to have to do another click to invoke an app.
With CDS Hooks, the hope is not only will in
response to say a clinical event or an open chart or something of that nature,
that a SMART app workflow can be kicked off.
But the notion of having CDS Hooks available as a tool for
a developer will pull in all of these CDS specific content,
companies that can create innovative apps,
lift patient care, and produce superior outcomes.
>>Where do you feel that EHR's with an app platform will take us in the coming years?
>>Well, that's a pretty big question.
I mean, I think that we know we've made great progress but if we
are truly to look at the promise of FHIR and the use of
open standards and the notion of the EMR as
essentially on a platform much like an iPhone or Android device.
The possibilities really if you think about them are endless,
but if I'm really to see,
to see into the future and see what I think that
potentially could be the grand vision of things.
The notion of the patient having access to their own data to be able to try
these multitude of consumer apps that these
thousands of consumer apps that are out there for chronic care,
whether it's diabetes, congestive heart failure, etc.,
we need FHIR and we need a robust ecosystem and
a platform to be able to allow developers to be able to build that.
Secondly, the notion of being able to feed data to
the research community so the notion of FHIR bundles being able to push data out.
So, in that situation,
you're not looking at FHIR as merely a tool to
live in operability but to really lift medicine,
as a whole, and drive the health of patients and really human beings in general forward.
>>Thank you so much.
>>Thank-